I spend my time delivering results for
the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden that's how I spend my
time I don't spend my time trying to
smear other Republicans
how great Ron really really great you
took the high road you will lose if this
is what you do he doesn't have a chance
in hell of defeating Donald Trump if
that is going to be his approach it's
not what Republican voters want to see
at this point he's going with the I'm
above this sort of approach on this
thing and they tried it in 2016. it did
not work it might have gotten you two
three four five six seven percent but
then Trump Consolidated support and
Consolidated and consolidated